ewige stadt schon mal gelogen oder uhr
verkauft und der captain lehrern mir
fragt wenn du christine ist schon jemand
wert von je chf die lagertechnik
festgemacht und der sieger von
praktischer theoretische blockbuster und
unser schönstes menschen lustig und ich
mich sehr und komische situation auch
schüler und schülerinnen einfach lernen
auftrag zu erfüllen so wie sie möchten
und punkt und ich glaube die bemüht sind
und nachher ersten ein glücklicher
werden die bearbeitung und zweitens
glaube ich halt das unternehmen wohl die
zu machen und die stellensuche williams
traf und fertigt in berlin gibt und je
doch bitte die den europawahlen zu haben
hallo wo die die unbedingt bluewater
bürger für die jungen aber kulant und
ich fing es jetzt auf die stadt hama
interessiert was sie interessiert
nützlich und nützlich finde ich habe
mein schwierigstes
es war schwierig zu wissen wie sich
mobile entwickler gemacht was gewusst
dass ich überhaupt muss einen zündenden
können erfolgreich sind 20 jahre was mit
ihnen die 20 jahre vorsieht einstellen
was sie deinen thron kassenprüfer das
ist ein ganz schön ist es wird das ganze
umfeld für 1 3 und aufwarten sie den
vorbereitungen ihrer ganz eigenen für
sehende volk unterstütze und dass sie
ihre potenzial an die entdecker und das
entfalten wenn andere kinder in der
schule sind darf am montag ihr erstes
hiltbrunner und seinem team bei der
arbeit zusehen wie sie menschen die
womöglich gar value vor der pause die
besseren ergebnisse auf der heimischen
raum kocht er hier gießen sowie der
praktische
weil holmes cooler im privatunterricht
den stoff in der regel schneller gelernt
haben bleibt ihnen mehr zeit als den
meisten volksschülern ihren hobbys und
leidenschaften nachzugehen und mit der
berufswelt in kontakt zu kommen
ob ihr dank autos schmuck bällen auf die
koppelung ist die tanne wird seine
nutzer was die lehre und mit dir tanz
größer wurde geklärt
wenn möglich sind wer kann ich ganz
großes vertrauen dass die findet ihres
eigenen empfinden dass wenn sie wieder
laufen und ich sehe alle sie dass die
motiviert sind dass sie im presse soll
intensiv nach erkannt dass wir wieder
zwei gesichter
[Musik]